[Applaudissements]
je dise
vous parlez ce soir de quelque chose qui
s'inscrit dans une transmission forte de
partage à travers le temps et surtout
attaché à des valeurs gustatives
importante qui devrait parler à tout le
monde ce soir il faut imaginer une
montagne enneigée
si on dans la neige un nuage éphémère la
dégustation
je vais vous parler ce soir de la
chantilly appétissant il faut imaginer
que ce produit est né au 16e siècle à
l'époque de catherine de médicis et
c'est un produit très simple qui
s'inscrit dans trois ingrédients très
importants qui sont de la crème du sucre
et de la vanille une manie une chantilly
c'est une appellation aujourd'hui une
appellation qui est protégé c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas aujourd'hui parler de
chantilly avec un arôme artificiel
à l'intérieur ce n'est pas possible
après ce qu'il va être intéressant avec
ce produit n'est au xvième siècle c'est
ce que vont faire les pâtissiers dans le
temps il faut imaginer qu'on ait une
certaine époque où les moyens de
conservation sont vraiment réduit donc
on va oublier la conservation par le gr
par l'alcool par le sel par le sucre
pour avoir une avancée technologique
avec l'arrivée du froid qui va permettre
pâtissier dans le temps de pouvoir
sublimer cette crème la rendre
appréciable à tout le monde
par cet équilibre de sucre il faut
imaginer que une crème chantilly au
départ 100 appellations c'était
simplement une crème fouettée au xvième
siècle il n'avait pas eu l'idée encore
d'ajouter du sucre à l'intérieur ce qui
va être intéressant c'est la première
fois ils vont ajouter du sucre
ils vont y ajouter 30 % de sucre à
l'intérieur 300 g au litre ce qui serait
impensable aujourd'hui dans le sens où
on ne supporterait pas de manger quelque
chose d'aussi sucre et l'arrivée du
froid va faire que les pâtissiers dans
le temps vont réduire le sucre de façon
drastique parce que la crème voir se
tenir plus facilement aujourd'hui en ce
qui me concerne je n'ajoute que 7 % de
sucre dans une chantilly donc imaginez
on a 23 % de sucre en moins dans un dans
un litre de crème
ce qui est énorme là où d'autres
pâtissiers sont encore à 10%
mais j'y viendrai un petit peu plus tard
ce qui va être important c'est de
s'attacher aujourd'hui
une valeur gustative forte au travers
d'un ingrédient dans la sélection aura
été faite au préalable au moins en ce
qui me concerne je vais vous parler de
crème de normandie de sucre pur cannes
de vanille de papouasie ou de nouvelle
calédonie celles qui ont mes préférences
aujourd'hui cette crème
elle va permettre de donner du plaisir
de révéler une pâtisserie d'apprécier un
moment agréable
une dégustation de plaisir de partage et
cette notion de sucre qui va être
maîtrisée va être très importante
aujourd'hui en ce qui me concerne j'ai
eu l'occasion au travers de mon parcours
de travailler dans paint ton et une
maison parisienne a eu une importance
particulière dans le sens où lorsque je
suis arrivé je ne comprenais pas ce que
je mange et je découvrais les
pâtisseries et j'étais déçu de cette
maison bicentenaire
parce que les recettes était pas
l'auteur de ce que j'imaginais
c'était pour moi quelque chose de
troublant
il fallait que je comprenne cette
mécanique du goût parce que c'est ça
notre métier c'est de goûter en
permanence de se rendre compte de
maîtriser d'être garant d'un savoir
faire et d'une qualité et le fait de ne
pas comprendre ne perturbe énormément
donc je me suis plongé dans l'univers de
ces recettes de ces pâtisseries pour les
goûters à plusieurs occasions je me suis
rendu compte que toutes ces recettes là
en fait était très peu sucré pour moi ça
a été une révélation qui guident encore
mon quotidien aujourd'hui dans le sens
où pourquoi s'attacher à sélectionner
des matières premières de qualité si
c'est pour les masques avec du sucre
donc mon idée elle était de leur faire
ce travail de fond parce que c'est ça
qui est beau dans un métier culinaire
c'est que rien n'y fit rien et à qui
tout est évolutif
on va bien on parle d'une chantilly
qu'est né au xvième siècle et qu'on
utilise encore aujourd'hui ce travail de
des sucres âge a été très important
parce que il m'a permis de percevoir les
saveurs d'une façon différente
on n'imaginait pas de manger un plat
trop salée pourquoi le faire avec du
sucre et donc c'est la même chose ça
brûle des saveurs sa masse que le palais
le palais c'est un muscle comme tout
type de muscles c'est duke
il peut gagner il peut perdre en qualité
et une fois que ce chemin est amorcée on
ne peut plus leur faire le pas en
arrière c'est à dire qu'une fois qu'on a
commencé à manger moins sucré on ne peut
plus consommer de la même façon qu'avant
moi je me verrais plus aujourd'hui par
exemple prendre un café sucré ce serait
impossible ça me perturberait je n'aurai
plus la notion de plaisir
cette notion de plaisir disparaît
totalement donc ça a été très très
important aujourd'hui et je pense que
c'est quelque chose d'actualité à
laquelle il faut s'attacher de revenir
une culture du goût aujourd'hui on perd
énormément cette culture du goût parce
que pendant que de temps parce qu'on
s'attache peut-être à moins d'importance
à cette qualité gustative et moi c'est
un de mes combats quotidiens de
retraduire au plus près le goût des
producteurs avec lesquels je travaille
il ya trois éléments forts qui sont les
garants d'un savoir faire culinaire pour
- essentiellement à laquelle j'attache à
laquelle j'attache beaucoup d'importance
c'est le goût le savoir faire je vous en
ai parlé et la transmission
ces trois piliers vont agir en résonance
perpétuelle dans mon quotidien
ces trois piliers on les retrouve dans
les métiers de l'artisanat pour moi dans
tous les métiers d'artisanat et dans le
monde culinaire ils se traduisent aussi
par le concours de meilleur ouvrier de
france
ce concours est un concours titanesque
intense dans lequel on va passer deux
années de travail intense pour décrocher
ce col blanc rouge que j'ai aujourd'hui
qui est un diplôme d'état donc il faut
penser qu'on est le seul pays au monde
où l'état donne une distinction aussi
forte métiers d'artisanat
on ne trouvera ça nulle part ailleurs
dans le monde
donc c'est un engagement une qualité
d'être le garant d'un savoir faire
autour d'un patrimoine culinaire
en ce qui me concerne en 2011 puisque ce
concours et tous les quatre ans
le thème était la pâte et cif la
pâtisserie française patrimoine
universel de la gastronomie
ceci parce que
2010 la gastronomie française est rentré
au patrimoine immatériel de l'unesco
c'est fort notre gastronomie française
au patrimoine de l'unesco
moi j'ai décidé de travailler cette
thématique autour des jardins à la
française
parce que je trouvais ce parallèle fort
puissant parce que beaucoup de nos bases
de notre métier qui soit sucré ou salé
sont nés à l'époque de ses châteaux au
travers des diverses réceptions qui
étaient effectués je vous ai parlé de la
chantilly bien sûr louis xiv qui est qui
a quand même été un révélateur de
beaucoup beaucoup de recettes au travers
de ses différentes réceptions et moi je
trouvais cette transversale très
intéressante à travailler c'était rendre
hommage
quelque part aujourd'hui ce qui nous a
été transmis non moi je vais travailler
autour d'une façon graphique au travers
de pièces en sucre 2e mettant en valeur
le journal française mais de façon
graphique autour de pièce en sucre de
pièces en chocolat d'éléments moteurs de
code couleur fort qui rappelait les
éléments solaire mais ce qui a été
puissant c'est cette aventure humaine
qui est drainée autour du meilleur ou et
de france parce que au-delà d'un savoir
faire et d'un goût on est aussi garant
d'une transmission derrière ce concours
et se colle il est fort parce qu'il
engage une certaine responsabilité
derrière on passe de réalisateur à
transmetteur ça c'est fort et c'est
puissant et c'est quelque chose à
laquelle j'ai pris conscience qu après
le concours de mof
je me suis attaché aujourd'hui à rendre
tout ce qui m'avait été donné à mon tour
c'était que moi aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance à travers mon métier de voyage
énormément dans le monde et de faire
découvrir mon métier de faire découvrir
ma perception du sucre la transmission
s'effectue de différentes façons et
s'effectue ce soir avec vous
à massy à s'effectuer avec mes équipes
dans ma boutique assure les chartreux ou
à travers mes différents voyages dans le
monde et les écoles à laquelle je
m'attache à former les élèves alors
retranscrire au plus près cette émotion
qui draine mon quotidien et ma
philosophie du goût et du peu sucré
mais le rôle de mère ou et france c'est
aussi faire évoluer son métier le rendre
pérenne dans le temps moi aujourd'hui
j'ai eu par chance ou par erreur le
bonheur d'inventer une technique qui est
aujourd'hui reprise partout dans le
monde qui s'appelle le tourbillon
cette technique consiste à approcher une
crème sur un tour de potier donc au
départ c'est une création un peu folle
qui est né sur une galette des rois qui
s'est transformée après sur une
pâtisserie et qui est devenue ma
signature et qui a été reprise partout
dans le monde
aujourd'hui je suis fier de me dire que
j'ai laissé une trace dans mon métier au
travers de cette technique forte au delà
de cette technique
ce qui a beaucoup plus enthousiasmé les
pâtissiers et le monde culinaire à ce
moment là c'est que c'est un geste
pâtissier c'est un geste manuel le
travail de la poche le travail d'une
crème le travail de la main dans la
continuité de l'esprit rendre un visuel
fort au travers de cette technique
mais au delà du fait de créer des
techniques il faut aussi s'attacher à la
création gustatives
aujourd'hui je suis pas fan de suivre
les modes mais par contre je me suis
rendu compte que je faisais part des
recherches culinaire beaucoup de choses
qui étaient sans gluten aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est important parce que j'y
attache une importance gustatives et que
le goût est présent de proposer une
offre sans gluten aujourd'hui pour
contenter un peu tous les palais et ça
ça donne de l'actualité du plaisir aux
gens
moi mon plus grand bonheur c'est de voir
les gens heureux les gens me remercient
d'attacher une importance à leur
restituer au plus près des belles de
matières premières une pâtisserie c'est
pour moi c'est ça c'est le le plaisir du
moment le plaisir d'un partage un
réconfort et après tout n'est ce pas
cela une pâtisserie une résonance mais
qui vient de l'intérieur
merci de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]